[Music]
[Music]
Carolyn winter is the Anthony P Meyer
family professor in the humanities and
she's the director of the Stanford
Humanities Center and we have her
previous book American enlightenment on
sale in the back she'll be signing these
after the talk and we'll get her to tell
us a little bit more about this as well
but right now without any further delay
let's have a big round of applause and
rate Carolyn to the stage
[Applause]
wonderful well thank you Michael for
that excellent introduction and thanks
to all of you for coming here and thanks
to david and abby Rumsey for in some
senses really helping to inspire this
project since we had our conference last
year at the Rumsey map Center and to
really push my thinking forward about it
what better place to talk about deep
time than the long now foundation what I
hope to do today is to think with you
about the first moment in our history
when we begin to think in terms of what
we can call the long now so the long now
as I understand it from the website is
10,000 years from now maybe 20,000 maybe
30,000 but that range of time that sheer
length of time is extraordinary and it's
unimaginable in many ways and yet we
love to imagine it and to think with it
so what I want to do with you today is
to bring you back to the moment in
American history
when we began to think that it was
possible to think in those large
chronological chunks of time so you can
leave the long now foundation at the end
of the evening knowing that not only are
you thinking in terms of this
extraordinary long period of time but
that in some ways you are thinking in
ways that are radically new and
radically revolutionary so let's begin
by looking at the image of deep time if
you google the term deep time this
evening when you go home and you hit
image this is the image that you will
get it is a wonderful image and I wish
that I could show it to you very
close-up because it profits from your
close examination this is an effort to
show the history of the earth in a
single image a 4.6 billion history
of the earth that begins over here in
this tiny little dot and then spreads
through this ever-widening slinky figure
all the way up to the present which is
here and the Californians in the room
will be delighted to know that all of
history culminates in a surfer that's
like really want you to look when you
open it up on your screens at home but
this is a really interesting image
because it captures what's very hard to
capture in a single frozen image which
is the passage of time and it also is in
no particular place this is pure time
removed from a particular geographical
space we are simply in the history of
the earth moving through geological time
periods so you'll see that we go through
the Cambrian and you know life starts
with a single cell and then we continue
to unfold and suddenly we're in the
dinosaurs and then we're here with our
surfer and that is deep time represented
there are many many ways of representing
deep time you can find a whole lot of
them on the web and what we're gonna do
today is see the historical origin of
this particular and rather strange way
of conceptualizing the past but before
we do that you might ask yourself why is
this person interested in doing this so
I actually grew up at the beach in
Southern California in the little town
of Del Mar and every summer we would go
up to the Mammoth Lakes area in the
Sierras and in order to do that you have
to travel up 395 which is a beautiful
stretch of highway if you love barren
desert and a horrible stretch of highway
if you don't like barren desert this is
what it looks like this is me as a small
child a very small child sitting in my
parents car as we took the eight-hour
drive up the Owens Valley in order to
get to Mammoth Lakes now in the 70s when
I was a child there were no devices so
so there was nothing to do in the car
after we had made the yarn dolls that my
mother had brought along and so I would
look out the window and for those of you
who have been into the Owens Valley this
is what you see and I think deep time
was what I thought the length of
the car trip actually was but it was
actually the kind of experience of
seeing the extraordinary mountains the
white mountains on my right and the
Sierra Nevada on my left over about a
six-hour period going up and down the
valley that first caused my imagination
to wonder how is it that these things
could happen how is it that these
mountains formed on each side of me how
is it that these geological processes
unfolded and how extraordinary that this
happened over such a long period of time
and that I could see none of it
happening right now so now as a
historian at Stanford I'm able to look
at these things from a historical
perspective I'm not a geologist but I
like to imagine how geologists and
others first imagined deep time so that
is why I'm interested in it we're going
to talk about the origin of deep time
today and what I want you guys to really
appreciate is the rapidity which which
the deep time revolution occurred in the
American past we could also say that it
happened in the European past but we're
just going to talk about the United
States today the deep time revolution
the capacity to think that the history
of the earth and life upon it was not a
mere six thousand years old but in fact
was 1 billion 2 billion 3 billion 4
billion years old occurred within the
space of a single century and that
century was between the American
Revolution in 1776 and basically the
moment when the car was invented so this
is an extraordinarily broad
reorientation of the human psyche and
and the way we conceptualize our place
within the universe and it happened
within the space of a hundred years so
how does such a thing happen how do we
go from imagining that that the earth is
6,000 years old to four billion years
old and that's what I'm going to show
you very quickly right now ok before the
American Revolution in the 17th
trien before people actually imagined
that the earth was 6,000 years old so
why do they think the earth was 6,000
years old well they thought the earth
was 6,000 years old because the Bible
told them so
there was an archbishop in the 17th
century named Archbishop Ussher
and he calculated by reading the Bible
very very literally that in fact God had
created the earth in 4004 BC on a
Wednesday in October and not not joking
this is what Archbishop Ussher did and a
lot of the early geological treatises
one of which you're seeing here
extrapolated from that to imagine the
history of the earth that included the
Americas that was only 6,000 years old
so how does all this happen well so the
idea was that God created the earth
6,000 years ago and then people began to
be very very bad which you know from the
Bible and so there was this gigantic
flood with a capital F that came along
and God rebooted humanity and and life
upon it so the this first geological
text shows that the earth is covered
with this flood and the arrow is
pointing to this tiny little Noah's Ark
being borne aloft by angels I just had
to point that out to you because it was
just so charming the idea also is that
the Americas as the hemisphere that is
discovered last emerged last from the
flood waters this inspired a lot of
understandings of life animal plant and
human life in the Americas in the 18th
century they believed that all life
forms in the Americas were inferior to
European life forms because the
continents of the Americas had arisen
laso so they were colder and wetter like
you are when you get out of the tub and
they were therefore inferior life-forms
don't don't inquire too much into the
science because it doesn't bear a lot of
close examination but that was how
people understood the history of the
earth
before the American Revolution now let's
fast-forward to a mere hundred years
afterward when it was widely believed
thanks to a series of new scientific
understandings that many parts of the
earth were at least 2.2 billion years
old and I'm pointing to you to the
Canadian crate ons the Canadian Shield
which is some of the oldest rocks in the
world there are other ones in Australia
and South Africa so that's an
extraordinary change in how people
understand their own place in the
universe to think that the earth used to
be 6,000 years old and now it's at least
2.2 billion years old
not only how do you get there but how do
you even begin to understand that how do
you draw pictures of that how do you how
do you put that into your mind and to
make sense of it so what we're gonna do
is to look at some of the first images
that people began to create in order to
understand what is essentially
non-understandable so first they begin
to look at maps differently so I'm just
showing you a map now and this is just
your basic 18th century map it's not
particularly interesting I hesitate to
say that in front of the Rumsey sorry
about that but this is just this is I
just took a map a mapping map right that
is supposed to show space right so this
is North America as it was seen in the
18th century within a few decades
the first geological maps of the United
States began to be created and this is
one of the first ones what makes it
geological well what makes it geological
and this is from 1809 is that this
coloring represents the age of the rocks
that are being represented so the key is
over here so the yellow rocks are the
newest rocks and the orange rocks are
the oldest rocks we take these kinds of
maps for granted we look at this we said
this is a geological map these are the
young rocks these are the old rocks this
was radically new in the 18th century to
imagine that America could be
represented not as a series of political
entities or jurisdictions of economics
but actually as a series of time lapses
here is another example from around the
same time period this is really
incredible this is the first cross
section map of the United States if you
could come up closer and look at it you
could see that over here we are starting
essentially at the Atlantic Ocean and
here we are ending in the Ozarks and
what we are looking at is a vertical
access of feet which shows us the time
period that we're in and a horizontal
axis of where we are in space there's a
long line at the top of the image that
says supposedly of the primitive ocean
so they are imagining they're still kind
of operating with what we call flood
geology you know that the earth is about
six thousand years old but they're not
indicating the precise date because
they're they're starting to become a
little uncertain about it but the idea
was that sometime in the past there was
a great ocean and then at some point it
began to recede but what's really
extraordinary about this map is this is
the first time that we basically have
the United States as a layer cake and a
map that takes a knife and cuts through
it and shows us the United States not as
politics but as developing through time
through the very earth itself we
basically have an XY axis for
understanding the past of the United
States now as all of this is happening
they're beginning to have the Industrial
Revolution so when I showed you the car
at the end of the video from where we
are coming to where we are going the car
was not chosen accidentally the American
interest in the past of the deep pass of
their country was very much inspired by
the Industrial Revolution by trains and
roads being literally cut through the
rocks of the United States and in those
rocks they began to see strata and in
the strata they began to see fossils and
they began to ask themselves what are
those fossils where did they come from
and most importantly where did they come
from so one of the fossils that they
began to find was this a trilobite
and that's actually what otto was was
drawing
over here the trilobite began to emerge
in the cambrian and the Silurian so
they're very very old and Americans
began to find these in the railroad cuts
that they were making through the rocks
of the United States they began to talk
to people in England who were also
finding tryla bites and they began for
the first time now again we take this
for granted but it was not until the
1830s that people in Britain and the
Americas began to imagine that those two
areas of land had once been connected so
this is a new geological understanding
of a past that is beginning to stretch
very far back in time so next time you
see a trilobite be excited about it the
the Industrial Revolution is also
important because they are finding
evidence of a time in the past in
Earth's history that was full of what
they now called and this is a new term
coined in the 1830s fossil fuels fossil
fuels is a term that is coined in the
early 19th century precisely during the
deep time revolution they're cutting
through the earth they're looking for
fuel to power the Industrial Revolution
they find an era a lost era full of palm
trees from a time when the whole were
earth was like the Amazon a kind of what
they called a Carboniferous an era of
carbon and this was going to become
here's another key word from this time
period the natural resource that would
power the Industrial Revolution so the
Industrial Revolution the cars the
trains are all part of the new ways of
approaching the earth that helped get us
to deep time ok deep time is great but
it brings up a bunch of new problems and
these are so interesting and I give them
to you not as me telling you what to
think but as partners with me in
thinking about how difficult this is to
think about so deep time presents a
number of issues let me just give you
the first one the first thing is the
deep time is an inconceivable concept
Charles Darwin is one of the many people
in the 19th
who thinks about deep time right
evolution has to happen over deep time
and he says it is in comprehensively
vast he is one of many others who look
at the idea of deep time that the earth
is not 6,000 but maybe 10 million 20
million 4 billion years old and says
that maybe so but I cannot conceive of
that so it's this startling new concept
that by its very nature is an
inconceivable concept so this is
wonderful for historians like me who
like to imagine how people think about
their world to imagine a new idea that
you cannot think about is an absolutely
extraordinary thing that is very very
fun for us to think about so deep time
also has a second problem with it which
is that it is existentially horrifying
one thing we know about human beings is
that we like to be the center of the
universe nothing matters unless we are
part of it unless we are folded into our
own history of the universe and the
history of the earth it's hard to
understand why it should matter and deep
time presents this problem in a really
really palpable way the Bible ultimately
is about human beings and how you get
from then to now and the Bible has at
it's very center this sense that human
beings are God's special creation deep
time does not have that assurance it
removes humanity from the story of life
on earth from the story of Earth from
the story of the cosmos you can have as
many strata as you want but if none of
them contain human beings and if none of
them contain the things that human
beings are good at doing which is having
events right we have events we have
events like this one and events leave
documents they leave traces in the
historical record
none of those are present in these
strata so the strata present to people
who could not before had imagined
anything longer than a 6,000 year
history that was in a document it was in
the Bible the Bible had nothing to say
about strata so this was very very
unsettling a book in which we were not
even the act not not just not act not
the main actors but not actors at all in
it so what do you do to fix this problem
well in the 19th century we see a number
of solutions emerging to this problem
which is to try to make the
inconceivable concept of deep time
conceivable not only conceivable but as
we saw with the slinky unwinding of the
Earth's history in the thing that you're
gonna look at later on when you go home
to make it beautiful to make it
relatable to make it in some ways part
of our own humanity when in fact we know
deep doubt down inside that deep time
doesn't really have humanity necessarily
as part of it so what do some of these
images look like some of these are gonna
be familiar to you but I hope that from
now on you look at them as the evidence
of the the birth of deep time so this is
one of the many images to come out of
some of the Grand Canyon exploring
expeditions of the 1870s 1880s and 1890s
this is William Henry Holmes painting of
the Grand Canyon this is incredible
right this is like strata central
looking down into the Grand Canyon you
see all of these layer cakes of time and
look at these teeny tiny human beings
they're totally insignificant in this
larger canvas but it is so incredibly
beautiful that you don't care and it is
so incredibly beautiful and I'm just
giving you things to think about right
you don't have to agree with me just
think about this bear
me it is so incredibly beautiful that
even though it is existentially
horrifying even though we as human
beings are insignificant we imagine that
perhaps something like the deity might
be there because it is so transcendently
beautiful and it makes us think about
eternity in the way that people in the
18th century and before thought about
eternity so one way to think about deep
time images is as the secularization of
the crisp the judeo-christian idea of
the cosmic eternity in the face of the
scientific revolutions of the 18th and
19th century here's another example of a
deep time image this is the Kansas this
is Kansas in the 19th century as seen in
1872 when they first began to imagine
that the Midwest right the flyover
country as we call it now was an inland
sea this is they're starting to find the
bones of these wonderful sea serpent
like animals this is one of the very
first landscape images of the great
Inland Sea that once covered the United
States that emerges after the Civil War
now what I love about this is that the
characters are so funny you know they're
laughing they're playing in the water
and there's this sort of Superman one
flying overhead these these again bear
close examination
here's another deep time image this is
great the originals are at Princeton so
next time you're at Princeton please do
have a look this is a landscape painting
of Cretaceous life in New Jersey please
look at this more closely at home
where's my pointer here I just have to
point out so many things to you on this
okay these guys look at these guys here
there's these kind of thuggish
characters dancing and there's a kind of
attack of the snakes coming closer here
and this is an attempt to represent
these lizard light creatures in an era
that had just named
the dinosaurs so you know we again we
look at images like this of dinosaur
paintings and we say yeah of course
their dinosaur paintings but this all
had to be invented over the course of
the 19th century so first you get these
disembodied trilobite slike i showed you
from the 1820s and 1830s but look what
has happened to the visual imagination
essentially by the Civil War era is that
suddenly they're able to imagine this
canvas where you would have a perfectly
good landscape painting but instead of a
bunny rabbit you have a dinosaur this
again is it requires a real turnover in
people's imagination to think that New
Jersey once looked like this now for
those of you who are big fans of the
Hudson River school of painting Thomas
Cole all of these others and please
imagine them next time possibly as
images of deep time I'm showing you one
example here this is Martin Johnson
heeds beautiful painting of Lake George
from 1862 now this is not Lake George up
in Mammoth Lakes this is Lake George in
upstate New York when you first look at
this painting there's absolutely nothing
that is exceptional about it it looks
like your basic Hudson River school type
of painting there's a pretty lake
there's some clouds there's some
mountains there's some people in the
boat end of conversation
but look more closely and you actually
see that he'd understands the geological
past of Lake George he understands that
it is the product of a recent Ice Age
and that at some point huge glaciers
blanketed North America and upon
receding scraped the ground along this
big rock and left great boulders in very
strange places also known as glacial
erratics
here's an example right here of a
glacial erratic now again and I have a
little close-up for you here so art
historians call these rock portraits
things that look like just your basic
generic landscape painting but in fact
the lake is not the subject of the
painting the
so the subject of the painting and
they're not only rocks they're rocks
from the recent Ice Age the Ice Age is a
concept that was invented in the 19th
century as a product of deep time we
don't think that it's exceptional or
strange or revolutionary but the idea of
the Ice Age or what they call and this
is for your next speaker they used to
call it the idea of periodic
refrigeration periodic refrigeration
another term for ice ages asks you to
imagine not just climate change but
climate variability it's a very
important distinction since about the
15th century people had imagined that
the earth had climate change so climate
change is not a new concept
the reigning theory of Earth's formation
was that it had emerged as a ball from
of hot like lava from the Sun and that
over about 500 years it had begun to
cool and that the end of the earth was
going to be as an ice ball so the
Earth's climate was changing but it was
just changing once it was changing from
very hot to very cold once they start
seeing glacial erratics once they start
seeing these scraped rocks they begin to
imagine that there was a time in the
past where the earth was colder than it
was now and so they had to imagine that
the Earth's had gotten hotter and colder
and hotter and colder climate
variability is built into the idea of
deep time as it emerges in the 19th
century and we inherit that idea today
and we're thinking through it in in
other ways ok final problem of deep time
that we're going to talk about tonight
if deep time is incomprehensible how
does the human brain actually understand
the deep time over which it is now
believed to have evolved so do i this is
like a tricky question right you got to
read this a couple times before you
understand what it means but basically
Darwin asks us to imagine that human
beings along with other animals and
plants emerged
/ deep time but over millions and
millions of years human beings changed
from essentially apes and monkeys into
the people that we have today the human
brain is therefore not just a product of
evolution but it is a product of deep
time how does the brain understand the
deep time over which it is believed to
have evolved so this also requires
conceptualization people had been
thinking about the brain for several
hundred years this is an example of how
you can look at different kinds of
brains over the course of the 18th
century so comparing brains thinking
about brains this idea is not new but
what you have in the 19th century is the
first effort to understand the human
brain in geological terms as the product
of deep time so the imagine that there's
a lower part of the brain that is very
very primitive and it can only
understand space in terms of time that
is it takes me three days to walk to
Menlo Park that is how far Menlo Park is
from here it takes me three days to walk
there
that's the primitive part of the brain
they think in the 19th century over time
the higher parts of the brain like
geological strata accreting begin to get
deposited in the human mind leading to
our modern advanced brains how do we
know they're modern and advanced is that
we can imagine time in terms of space we
have things like clocks that help us to
see time in spatial terms and this is a
sign of how advanced we are so the human
brain begins to be imagined like a
geological stratum in the 19th century
that it's strata like rocks are layered
through time now let me show you how
that idea has crept into our way of
thinking and talking today in ways that
we didn't even know many
of us all of you in this room have
certainly used the term the
stream-of-consciousness
and you have probably used it without
understanding the origins of this term
well it emerges from the deep time
revolution in the writing of the Harvard
psychologist William James who studied
with the geologist Louis Agassiz at
Harvard and was very very influenced by
this new deep time way of thinking not
just about the earth as layered strata
but about the human brain as layered
strata so he tried to explain how you
could understand the flow of human
thought as a kind of geological process
so he asks you to imagine saying this
sentence the pack of cards is on the
table this is gonna bring back traumatic
memories of diagramming sentences in
seventh grade so I'm sorry because it
brought those back for me sorry mrs.
collie I didn't like diagramming
sentences but William James is asking us
to imagine and I actually I brought a
prop so here look at this the pack of
cards is on the table and he's asking
you to diagram what the brain is doing
as it is thinking that thought so and he
calls this the stream of consciousness
so here's what he's imagining remember
the XY axis I showed you earlier in the
talk this is exactly what he's doing
he's imagining you saying this sentence
the pack of cards is on the table and
the 1 2 3 & 4 is not grammatical right
it's just like time time is happening 1
2 3 4 and then he has this y-axis this
spatial dimension and what the space is
is not a kind of geological stratum but
it is what he calls the fullness of
thought so as you're saying the sentence
and as you're thinking it your mind is
getting fuller and fuller and fuller of
the thought of
pack of cards being on the table so that
at the end of the sentence you're way up
high with you're thinking about the pack
of cards being on the table now what's
interesting about this is that he says
if you put a knife through the center of
the thought imagine doing that put a
knife through the center of the thought
you would find it suffused with the
whole of all of the rest of the thought
just like a knife cutting through the
strata of the rocks that I have been
showing you would show you cutting
through all of the strata of the earth
so when you use the term the stream of
consciousness he means a stream in the
literal geological sense of the term
that our brains have thoughts running
through them that are like streams that
road through our minds and that we can
diagram them like a geological stratum
okay at the end of my time and I want to
end up back with our image today so this
looks like a very simple image of deep
time we are beginning 4.6 million years
ago we are ending in the now but now we
have a much more complicated
understanding of this very peculiar
image first of all we know that it is a
peculiar image then it is a strange way
of thinking about the world we know that
it presents cognitive dilemmas to us we
cannot think in our Darwin Lee
evolutionized brains of that amount of
time no matter how hard we try we cannot
imagine 4.6 billion years of time that
is impossible to do we do not know why
it is impossible to do but we know that
people in the 19th century began to ask
those questions we think the earth is
billions of years old why can't we think
about those billion years of time when
we know that our own brains evolved over
that amount of time
and so we develop images like this one
whose beauty and interest in a sense
Comus down to walk us back from the
existential horrors that deep time
presents to us and it reassures us that
even though the rest of history has
nothing to do with us it in fact all
culminates in a surfer you know so we
are actually part of the story so I want
to talk to you more during the Q&A about
how we want to look at these images now
where they come from in the past but in
the meantime let me thank you for giving
you my attention tonight
Thank You Carolyn thank you so much
well that was that that that was that
was what we're looking for this is
fantastic
cool so so let me ask you let's I'd like
to take a step back and and reframe the
timeline a little bit what where does
this is there a lynchpin is there an
actual kind of starting event for this
dawning of the realization is is there
something you would point to and and
what year is that just to sort of track
that yeah where can you find a starting
event for something that unfolds over a
hundred and twenty years I would say
that gosh it's hard to find a starting
event the publication of Charles Lyell's
principles of geology in the early 1830s
is this hugely important monument Lyell
is a geologist he's British he looks in
England he looks at the United States
he's the one who coins the term Natural
Resources so next time you used the word
Natural Resources thank Charles Lyell
he's the one who begins to say that the
earth is millions and millions of years
old that's the book that Darwin reads on
the Beagle when he's going to the
Galapagos and he begins to imagine that
the history of life on Earth is a
history of change an extinction and
constant renewal and that that could not
have happened over 6,000 years that had
to happen through the long time period
that Charles Lyell describes in the
principles of geology so one you know
his historians hate counterfactuals so I
can't even believe that I'm gonna give
you one right now
okay so pretend I didn't do this don't
tell anyone I'm sorry but the whole
history of the modern world would have
been different if Charles Darwin didn't
have Charles Lyell's principles of
geology in the early 18th published in
the early 1830s to read
in the voyage on the Beagle he would not
have had enough time for evolution to
unfold it just couldn't happen in 6000
years it just doesn't happen fast enough
yeah it reframes the problem in reframes
the situation yeah the way you talk
about it I think it's interesting it's
it's really kind of traumatic it's a
trauma that that civilization or the
people as they're starting to think
about in different disciplines are
they're traumatized by this changing in
the dimensions of what they're doing and
so it's interesting you talk about the
way that I think about how we conceive
of the long now today the initial things
are kind of reactions to trauma and
they're kind of it seems like adoptions
that are being made kind of on the fly
it's only after this time after this
much this farther away from the early
events that kind of shook us that we can
do what we try and do with the long now
and think of okay well everything's
stable now well let's look at 10,000
years into the future so we're not
reacting we're starting to be proactive
at least that's what I think we hope
we're doing here at long now oh yeah
absolutely and I mean this is a really
this is another interesting this is like
the twin brother or sister of deep time
is deep future and when the one of these
so there's traumas associated with deep
time as we saw today right with the kind
of highway Horror Show that I showed you
but but this has so many gifts attached
to it that it opens up an eternity into
the future so you know the
judeo-christian tradition also gives you
an eternity but it's an eternity that's
not within human control right you die
you go to heaven and that's the eternity
in the clouds but this is the gift of
the Enlightenment and then the deep time
revolution is that there is a new
eternity and it's going to in full
unfold on the earth not somewhere else
and so being the inheritors of this
extraordinary path
we now have this huge new responsibility
for a future without known end whoa what
a huge responsibility right we can't
farm it out to a deity it's all on us
yeah and even though we're not in the
center of it as you said even though
it's not arranged around us as a place
to work in we can actually become actors
in it once we see that it's open-ended
on the future side exactly exactly
we're gonna we're gonna get your
questions as well Rose are you out there
with Rose has the microphone so get her
attention she'll get you the mic and and
we'll get some of your questions and a
reminder to our folks that are on the
live stream as well so I want to just
kind of go through our glossary again so
ice age fossil fuels Natural Resources
the term fossil itself is that how does
that where does how does that a when
does the wind does that first get
reckoned oh I'd love these questions the
dream questioner so the word fossil just
means something from the ground those of
you who speak French like in Fuss is
like a place in the ground so it's just
stuff so they were finding fossils in
ancient among the ancient Greeks just
like big bones in the ground and it
wasn't until we get to the deep time
revolution that they say yeah they're in
the ground and the deeper they are the
older they are and so then that's when
we get the modern meaning of fossils is
not just something from the ground but
something from the ground that's really
really old and the stuff that's further
down in the ground is older than the
stuff higher up unless you've had some
serious folding of the strata so the
FOSDEM then the fossil fuel you know so
this is this is another thing so yeah we
again we did the existential traumas of
deep time but the way they begin to
imagine fossil fuels is literally as the
gifts of the earth to the Industrial
Revolution it seems almost kind of
naively sweet like thank you thank you
for the oil Santa Claus yes thank you
for the oil and and but this is how they
imagined it in the 1820s and 1830s that
an early Earth is
to our modern earth and it's saying here
here have some fuel because you are
better than we are because they believe
in this idea of linear progress so here
have some fuel for your Industrial
Revolution the past will power the
present so there's these wonderful
things that go along with it as well and
and one more question for me before we
get to your questions
so as we're seeing paintings that are
speaking to I mean these are paintings
that are bringing the news they're
bringing the science this is nature the
the journal is a painting it seems like
that so can you say something about how
did art and painting maybe specifically
because I don't know this but I'm
thinking it's media at that time more
active how can you say something about
how how is this unusual that ideas are
being communicated through through
through artworks yeah so I um I like to
not necessarily use the word art because
it's it's a value judgment when you say
something is art versus not art right
like this is this art or not art right
it depends on where it is and who's
looking at it and and all of those
things so I like instead to talk about
images and science is a very image happy
discipline scientists always use images
to convey their ideas and it is in fact
through images like diagrams that
scientific ideas become known to the
scientists and then known to the general
public so we shouldn't imagine that
science and art are these two set or
science and images are these two
separate things that occasionally talk
to each other but that they are
completely bound up together and in fact
the word visualization emerges in a
scientific context in the nineteenth
century and it emerges among these deep
time people how do we visualize this how
do we make it real what visual is
nation helps you to do is to get rid of
information that is confusing
overwhelming and therefore extraneous
and it helps you to focus on the things
that you believe you want to see so
graphs charts all these kinds of ways of
looking they are ways of blinding
yourself to some things and opening your
eyes to other things so it's focusing
it's a folk exactly yeah but we should
never imagine that scientists see nature
as it really is scientists through seed
nature by creating the proper images to
help them to see nature if that makes
sense and is that their conception I'm
trying to unpack that but is that is
that their conception of it or is that
your sort of analytical take on what
they're doing yeah this is how
historians of science view the active
activities of science scientists it is
so engrained in the way that we teach
science that it almost becomes a neutral
practice to scientists but it's an
essential part of the process of
recreating nature so that you can see
the parts that you do want to see and
and not see the parts that that are so
large and confusing that that they
render you unable to see it does that
make sense yeah okay okay and I think
we've got a question right back there
yeah so my question is about sense of
responsibility but I just need to give a
little personal context or the question
make some sense so since I committed
myself to the climate crisis is my thing
I have come to long long term thinking
and my thinking about the glaciers are
all melting them older than civilization
so the fossil fuels are 500 million
years old so it's literally putting
myself in the context of a five minute
million you're all storing while I being
present changing my daughter's diaper at
the same
and so my sense of responsibility
towards the future is also my sense of
responsibility to the legacy of humanity
but a lot of people today will say oh
you know the earth will go on we won't
be here you got any other the other they
they don't have any sense of
responsibility throw off their sense of
time that things will go on and change
and something else will happen is a way
of just not having a responsibility so
my question is this era how did this
sense of deep time affect or not any
sort of sense of responsibility towards
the world or towards humanity or the
yeah great question so the essentially
the environmental movement is born
during the deep time revolution in the
nineteenth century and it is born at the
same time because of this need to
secularize what before was a religious
sense of cosmic mystery that we were
responsible for nature as God's stewards
of nature but now as all of you know as
as God is receding from that world in a
sense nature is fully invested with
these sacred properties when you read
Emerson when you read Thoreau when you
read their friend when you look at the
paintings of the Hudson River School
people like the one I showed you they
are shimmering with a sense of cosmic
responsibility that before was
abstracted in religious texts and
religious practices and that now is
invested within nature so they
definitely have it and they too struggle
with you know in a sense they're like
atlas the responsibilities that before
had been placed on the shoulders of the
deity God had created the earth and and
when he was mad he could flood it and he
did flood it you know but that was all
coming from his endless creative
energies I'm speaking in the 18th
century right this is not me speaking
and channeling the 18th century but now
all of this was placed on human
shoulders that nature was a human
responsibility because we didn't know
where the deity was anymore Newton had
suggested that through this idea of
scientific laws so this emerges at the
same time it's one of the existential
crises that deep time brings along with
it you know it's small comfort to say
well you know we're gonna annihilate all
life on Earth we're just everything's
gonna get so hot we're all gonna melt
and that's gonna be it in two hundred
years there won't be a single human
being on earth that's okay because
there's been like six major extinctions
you know and and life has recovered and
and some people are saying that right
who cares you know the earth will go on
we just won't be part of it that's the
that's deep time talking but but there's
always that nugget of the earlier time
when it mattered to us that we were a
central part of the narrative of life on
Earth so so that crisis is meeting in
the 19th century yeah Abby Carroll is a
festival sorry fascinating talk a night
I hope you're taking a sabbatical soon
so oh you're so nice yes I am but Darwin
and Lyle because one thing that puzzles
me is incomprehensible as this is who
actually gave anybody permission to
think about the facts and understand
them as we do now we know that Charles
Lyell actually gave permission to Darwin
to take all the time he for evolution
but how do people wasn't just Darwin and
how do people give themselves permission
to think about yes essentially
nauseating yeah how do people give
themselves permission to think about the
existential e nauseating I think that I
don't know if I can answer that
particular question it raises the larger
question of how we give ourselves
permission to think any new and
dangerous idea and part of it involves
unthinking cherished old truths so to
begin to think of the long now we have
to unthink other things that we really
really really value like that the earth
cares if we're here or not you know so
part of it is giving themselves
permission to abandon everything that
goes along with the short chronology
getting rid of biblical literalism it's
no surprise that the higher biblical
criticism is of the Bible that's
happening in Germany and the United
States is is unfolding over the course
of the 19th century that Moses himself
did not just sit down and like write the
Bible all at once that it's this
patchwork of texts written at different
times for different purposes so so I
would say that it's a it's a
multi-pronged process that happens
across a variety of media but that it is
it's just intensely dislocating at a
really fundamental level you know this
is kind of where Freudian psychology
ultimately is from Freudian psychology
is is the psychology of archeology its
fossil psychology right so what's wrong
with you well it we must look into your
deep past to figure out what's wrong
with you and once we get that trilobite
and we extract it and look at it it's
gone
you'll be fine afterward but you know
Freud was very interested in Egyptian
archaeology he was very interested in
classical archaeology the idea of the
Oedipus complex all of these things
imagine the human psyche as a great
archaeology so so I don't know if it's
so much giving yourself permission I'm
gonna I'm gonna be thinking about your
question four months from now it's as
small pods of coping you know in various
parts of your life you you try to cope
here and then you say well now this
doesn't work anymore then you try to
cope here and then suddenly the whole
thing just falls apart and and Einstein
was part of that modernist cubist art
was another part of it none of it hangs
together anymore so just guys show that
past interval speakers ask the toughest
questions it's Abby Smith Rumsey you can
see her talk on our site and avi brings
up the very important topic of you are
working on a book from this material
right so so you've given us this amazing
opportunity to discuss this with you
while you are in the process can you
tell us a little bit more about where
you are in the process and what fills in
are there is it more detailed stories
are there whole areas that you haven't
yet explored can you characterize a
little bit what your process is at this
point yeah so I'm at the very very
beginning of the of the book process
right now it's actually it's a it's the
most fun part of the book where all this
possibility and and you haven't actually
finished the research or or done a ton
of the research to show that some of
your harebrained ideas are actually
totally unsupported by empirical
evidence so so yes so basically the book
is to write a history of deep time as it
unfolded over the 18th and 19th
centuries how we get from the American
Revolution to the car basically what I
showed you early on you know most
histories of geology deep times that are
set in Europe that's where the action is
and this is sort of like well so the
title of the book in my head is how the
new world became old and that's really
what happened over the course of the
19th century you
the new world was not just new because
Columbus quote discovered it you know we
know he didn't discover it right but you
know what I mean
the Columbus discovered it was new
because of what I showed you because
they believe that the Americas were the
last to emerge from the biblical flood
waters so it was new in both senses of
the term it was new for human new for
Europeans but it was also just new in a
cosmic sense and to go from believing
that to a hundred years later having
found the crate on the middle of the
ancient continent in the middle of
Canada in a hundred years and to think
that that's actually true you know the
only thing you know that's kind of more
revolutionary after that is the idea of
plate tectonics that the actions on the
edges the action is on the edges which
is kind of a metaphor for a lot of
things I think
but deep time is also and this is where
I kind of want to end up with a book
deep time is a precondition for deep
space we would not have had NASA and the
space program and Hubble and all of
those things without the the idea that
not just Earth's history but the history
of the cosmos itself expands not just in
time but in space so the term deep space
is coined in the 1920s and 1930s the
term deep time is coined by John McPhee
in 1981 in the book basin and range of a
beautiful beautiful book about his own
coming to terms with the plate tectonics
revolution of the 1960s he had gone to
Princeton during the 1950's when they
didn't know anything about plate
tectonics and then there was this big
revolution that said hey there's plates
and they move and that explains
everything
and so he took trips across the United
States with geologists in the wake of
the plate tectonics revolution to try to
understand how his whole frame of
reference had shifted in the wake of
this revolution he comes up with his
beautiful word deep time to talk about a
100-year old concept but he he himself
piggybacked on the term deep space
isn't that cool so there was the idea
that there was no term for it and then
there's
deeps but it gives rise to the deep
space idea and then that gives us the
term deep time I love that yeah so that
the book will hopefully be done in like
three or four years yeah which is no
time at all yeah we bet and and I want
to apologize I'm sure we'll have more
questions than we have time for you're
gonna be sticking around after this so
folks can come up and ask more questions
we've got another question over here
please wait thank you so much professor
been doing it for about twenty years
more and more as possible more paralyzed
because we're also in a moment time work
so many inconceivable things are
happening very rapidly
he's got a y-you got blockchain you've
got climate change you've got you know
teen hacking you can go on and on but I
find the use of history increasingly
important to get them unstuck so thank
you so much for doing that it's because
it reminds them about that sense of
possibility and that big changes that
have happened in the past yeah but they
still say stuck right yep um and then I
have to get them into seeing all the
innovations in the present that could
add up to something very very different
and an exponentially different so my
question is for you and the group the
High Line is you know if Strada was the
metaphor of this period of time what are
the what are the metaphors now that are
sort of influencing ours our sense of
time is it the web is it are there
networks and who's the drummer who are
the Charles Lyell's of now yeah that
might completely reframe how we think
about time I love that question
all right well and and it's interested
resonates was something that I was
thinking too which is it you're pointing
to the power of metaphors when you show
that that that that looking at the brain
and there's something very readily there
as we look at this genetic work and
they're parallel with computer
programming but actually that that is is
in a way cycling back to earlier sort of
biological ideas that led into the
dawn of computing so there's there's an
interesting kind of back and forth
between those two worlds and some of
those are metaphorical and some of them
are cooler or design-based because the
metaphor leads to a design that then
becomes that you've expressed a metaphor
in how you built the thing which is
fascinating and I'm sure that there are
technological things that were built
along that geological model after all we
talked about stacks from a technology
standpoint so so there's there's a
layering going on here but what are what
on that yeah one of the things I love
about giving talks about work that's
just early in its gestation process is
that I get great questions that help me
to think it through so I don't have
answers to everything but I would say
that one of the key words of now is the
word Network now why it's important is
because it is non stratigraphic so the
word network is not coined until very
late in the 19th century and what that
and I would also say we can only speak
in metaphors we don't just talk we
always talk through images to try to
make concrete abstractions so Network
emerges because it is a way of talking
about human communication that is in the
absence of any depth to it so it is non
geological so it talks about the
communication revolution of the late
19th century suddenly you have trains
you have roads you have the Telegraph
you have simultaneity right that's the
thing that Einstein is trying to figure
out simultaneity
so networks are about shallow shallow
connection it is the very opposite of
the way they're thinking about
everything else in the 19th century
through these deep structures Karl Marx
thinks about class geologically right
that there are these proletariat and
there's the capital owners and and and
the perpetual stirring of that
geological stratum is the engine that
drives history forward
we'll introduce the metaphor of the
network which we love today
you immediately erase the Marxist
analysis of class conflict you erase
class that's the beauty of Facebook
it is connection through network where
class is absent so so that is a metaphor
of the way that we today are struggling
with how we think about differences
among human beings differences in our
economic structures so I think somebody
somebody needs to write a book about the
power of the metaphor of network in the
twentieth century and to go back to
something earlier that I said about how
scientists work we all work that way
right we use metaphor not just to see
but to unsee things that we do not want
to see and the network as a metaphor for
human interaction that is surface
without depth present without past is a
really powerful organizing metaphor for
the modern period and worth pondering
and and that's remarkable that you
explain it that way because the last two
or a couple of the last arts the last
seminar was about the decentralized
blockchain is this decentralized
approach so they so that network still
has a hierarchical aspect even if it's
not layered its centralized so Facebook
is at the middle of it and and there's a
there's a lot of fascinating discussion
and blockchain technologies and some
other technologies and and the brian
behlendorf talk that we had here and the
one bennett talk that we had in the
seminar series which you can see online
is are looking at d centralizing those
things that require us to have a nexus
point to to distribute or to to go a
server a single server in the middle
that that now it can be distributed
across that so that's that
definitely worth pondering
before we before we wrap up let's talk
about the book we do have in hand here
tonight so your book American
enlightenment and you are I mean would
you your your expertise is or one of
your focuses on the Enlightenment yeah
can you can you tell us about this and
also connect how that having having done
this that that you've come to this as
your next subject yeah so this book came
out in 2016 and we've learned that
paradoxically the paperback is way more
expensive than the hardcover these are
cosmic mysteries it's caused us
existential honks so yeah when I wrote
this book what I realized is so what we
what do I do it Sandra I'm an historian
of ideas what fascinates me is how
people think about their world I'm in
Festiva matter how you think about the
world I'm fascinated by how people in
the past thought about their world and
how people change their minds I'm just
fascinated that people change their
minds and how they go about doing it
which was which was part of Abby's
question so the American Enlightenment
was really fundamentally about hope the
idea that we as human beings could make
tomorrow better than today through sheer
human effort that's fundamentally what
it's about they thought they could do it
in every realm of their lives in society
in economics in government they thought
Kings were bad Kings were bad because
they would bring us into the Dark Ages
which and they're the ones that called
the dark ages the dark ages because they
were not enlightened and I thought these
people were really really interesting
because they were people who took 2,000
years of history and decided that it
didn't apply to them any longer you know
and that they were really really
courageous they weren't always right
they never finished the product the the
project we're still trying to do what
they set in motion
you know the month Jefferson died in
1826 he said all eyes are opening to the
Rights of Man you know that's like
almost 200 years ago and our eyes are
still opening to the rights of man but
we would say of humanity of human we're
still deeply concerned about human
rights and this these are projects that
the Enlightenment set in motion so the
book looks at those projects in various
aspects of American life the idea that
the the sort of radical idea for example
that slavery was wrong well it hadn't
been wrong for 3,000 years
so why did it suddenly become wrong in
the 18th century the chapter all books
emerge out of earlier books I think so
the book the law the deep time book that
I'm writing now emerges out of a chapter
in here that is called seashells in the
Appalachians and and it was about the
people like Jefferson who climb up into
the Appalachians you know in their
little 18th century short chronology way
you know and they say hey their shells
and from the sea why are they here and
what can we do to explain this and and
they were so interesting and so charming
and they they had a couple people who
were picking it this was so clear that
it was an unsolved project that I
thought man somebody's got to write the
long the long version of that so so
that's what I'm up to now
all right well three or four years huh
well so by academic standards that's
just the blink of an eye I tell you that
is just not that all right yeah well
please please stick around you're gonna
stick around here and as we have
conversations with you you're gonna tell
us oh that term was only invented in
1920 I have for you the long now
challenge coin which features of
Bristlecone pine
as a thank you for speaking for us
tonight let's give a big round of
applause for Carolina
[Music]